hello everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
today
we'll discuss a type of probability
distribution function that is bernoulli
distribution
so before we move ahead let's discuss in
brief what is a probability distribution
a probability distribution is a
statistical function
that describes all the possible values
and probabilities for a random variable
within a given range
they are bounded by the minimum and
maximum possible values
but
where the possible values we plotted on
the probability distribution will be
determined by a number of factors the
mean standard deviation and some of the
factors
so let's discuss the agenda for today's
session
we'll start by discussing what is
bernoulli distribution and the
probability distribution function for
the bernoulli distribution
then we'll see an example and some real
world example where we can use the
bernoulli distribution
finally we'll work on an example of a
bernoulli distribution in python
so let's begin
what is bernoulli distribution
bernoulli distribution is a discrete
probability distribution representing
the discrete probabilities of a random
variable
which can be taken only one of the two
possible values such as one or zero
success of failure yes or no in this
manner
for example the probability of getting a
head while you flip a coin is 0.5
and the probability of failure is 1
minus p that is 0.5 as well
the probability distribution function of
a bernoulli distribution can be
calculated by the following formula p to
the power x 1 minus p to the power 1
minus x
where x is equal to 1 is for the success
and x is equal to zero is for the
failure
suppose
there are approximately one out of fifty
bus
are twins
and one set of new parents is chosen
what is the probability that the parents
that are chosen where of a twin
so here the bernoulli distribution will
come into play
we have the probability as 1 by 50 that
is 1 out of 50 will be a twins
so the probability of success that is x
is equal to 1 will be 1 by 50 to the
power 1 into 1 minus 50 that is the
probability of failure to the power 0
which will come out to be 1 by 50.
so there's a 1 by 50 chance that the
prior institution will be a parent of a
twin
let's see some more situation where we
can use bernoulli distribution suppose
in a voting a person voted for a
particular political party or exchange
from voting so the success
is equal to one if the person has voted
for the particular party
the rolling of a die that will result
into a six or not
the success will come out of the die
equal to six
the third example we can look for is
whether the outcome of an interview is a
recommendation for the next round of
interviews or not if it is a success
then the result of the interview is
recommendation for the next round of the
interview
now let's move on to python to see how
you can use the bernoulli distribution
and code in python
let's start by importing some of the
important libraries that we'll require
here
the first one will be matplotlib that is
the matplot library
from
sci-fi will
import the bernoulli distribution
we'll declare an instance where
probability will be equal to 0.0.7
the outcome of the experiment will be
either is equal to 0 or 1.
we'll create a bar plot with a figure of
size five into five or six introduces
whatever you feel like
will create the graph of the bernoulli
distribution that we have declared above
with the variable x
let's keep the color of the graph as
anything green
so
let's just run the code and see if you
have any error or not
no the code works perfectly fine with
the 0.7 as a probability
and this is one minus p and that is the
probability of failure that we'll cover
to be 0.3
let's just add the labels on the axis
so for that
we'll just mention the
plot dot x label
axis will be values
of random
variable
and similarly the plot dot y label will
be
just copy this
will be the probability
since we have the probability on the y
axis
let's keep its font size also
[Music]
15 will add the font size above as well
so just copy this
okay so let's just run it yeah
we have the probability we have the
values of random variable and we have
the probability
so this is how you can use the python to
create the bernoulli distribution and
run some experiments here
so with this we have come to an end to
this tutorial i hope you like this video
and if yes please subscribe to our
channel to never miss an update
until then thank you again and happy
learning
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here